[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo
de áfrica 7 días este es un magazine
dedicado al continente africano mi
nombre es andrés meza muñoz y estos son
nuestros titulares
siguen las protestas en sudán tras el
golpe de estado del 25 de octubre más de
10 personas han muerto en medio de la
represión de las fuerzas de seguridad
pero los manifestantes dijeron que
continuarán su lucha hasta que los
militares entreguen el poder a un
gobierno civil
inicio en glasgow la esperada cumbre
sobre el clima áfrica llega al encuentro
con demandas por las promesas
incumplidas para mitigar los efectos del
calentamiento global que afectan a un
continente que apenas representa una
mínima porción de las emisiones de gases
de efecto invernadero
y nigeria se convirtió en el primer país
de áfrica en lanzar una moneda digital
se trata de la y nayra que lleva el
mismo nombre que su moneda nacional el
presidente del país aseguró que esta
medida facilitará las transacciones y
contribuirá significativamente a la
economía del país
empezamos en sudán una semana después
del golpe de estado cientos de miles de
personas atendieron el llamado de
activistas y salieron a las calles para
pedir la restauración del gobierno está
al igual que las protestas anteriores
estuvo marcada por la represión de las
fuerzas de seguridad que ignoraron los
llamados de la comunidad internacional a
respetar los derechos humanos unas 3
personas murieron durante las
movilizaciones del 30 de octubre y en
total serían más de 10 desde que
empezaron las protestas por el golpe los
líderes de las marchas dijeron que
continuarán las manifestaciones hasta
que los militares se entreguen el poder
a un gobierno civil
con banderas sudanesas decenas de miles
salieron a las calles de jartúm cerca
algunos manifestantes levantaban
barricadas con piedras y neumáticos
quemados todos exigen la salida
inmediata del general al burhan líder
del golpe de estado
estamos en la calle para echar atrás el
régimen militar de sudán que se mantiene
por 53 años hemos sido testigos de la
opresión y represión por parte del
ejército esperamos que sea el último día
de régimen militar en sudán
ante las concentraciones la onu y eeuu
habían advertido repetidamente contra el
uso de violencia esto tras la muerte de
más de diez manifestantes desde el
inicio de la semana llamados a la calma
que no impidieron la muerte de más
ciudadanos este sábado
los manifestantes piden la salida de los
militares del poder después de 2019 y el
fin del régimen de omar al bashir inició
un periodo de transición con una
división del poder entre civiles y
militares el golpe de estado del general
al burhan apartó a la parte civil del
poder comenzando con el primer ministro
abdalá hanbok arrestado en su residencia
el golpe ha puesto fin a la esperanza de
elecciones libres para 2023 y ha
profundizado aún más en la crisis del
país esta semana en eeuu y el banco
mundial suspendieron su ayuda financiera
a jartúm la conferencia de las naciones
unidas sobre el clima empezó en la
ciudad escocesa de glasgow una
delegación del continente africano
pedirá cuentas a los países ricos por
sus promesas incumplidas así como
propuestas más concretas para mitigar
los efectos del calentamiento global
mientras las concentraciones de gases de
efecto invernadero en la atmósfera
alcanzaron este año un nuevo récord
áfrica es el continente que paga el
precio más alto a pesar de ser sólo
marginalmente el responsable del cambio
climático
los países africanos llegaron buscando a
hacer oír sus voces y obligar a los
países ricos cumplir sus promesas
tras la cob de 2009 en copenhague las
mayores economías del mundo se
comprometieron a ayudar a los países en
desarrollo con 100 mil millones de
dólares al año hasta el 2020 una promesa
que no llevaron a cabo grandes de
copenhague llevamos más de 10 años
esperando la promesa de 100 mil millones
de dólares al año los delegados
africanos denuncian que su continente
está lidiando con el cambio climático
sin ser responsable de él los esfuerzos
propuestos por los países ricos están
lejos de lo que se necesita para
mantener la temperatura global por
debajo de 1.5 grados celsius como
acordado en 2015 en parís una situación
preocupante que da al grupo africano
argumentos legítimos para situar esta
cuestión en el centro de los debates es
una cuestión muy importante para áfrica
que podamos diseñar un desarrollo
económico compatible con el cambio
climático es importante saber que áfrica
no aceptará limitar su desarrollo
económico para acompañar la lucha contra
el cambio climático por eso pedimos
apoyo apoyo financiero apoyo en términos
de tecnología apoyo en términos de
desarrollo de capacidades según el
centro global de adaptación áfrica sufre
los efectos del cambio climático con
mayor fuerza el año pasado sudán se
enfrentó a las peores inundaciones de
los últimos 60 años provocando el
desplazamiento de 500.000 personas en
2019 dos ciclones destruyeron a la
ciudad de beira mozambique matando a
1300 personas y afectando a un total de
3.5 millones los expertos científicos
destacan también los problemas de
seguridad en áfrica un tercio de los
conflictos entre 1980 y 2016 fueron
precedidos por una catástrofe natural
cientos de personas protestaron en mali
el pasado 29 de octubre para pedir a
francia que retira sus tropas del país
los militares han estado luchando contra
grupos yihadistas pero la violencia
continúa meses después del golpe militar
la comunidad internacional la onu y la
comunidad económica de estados de áfrica
occidental han llamado a restaurar el
proceso democrático pero los
manifestantes aseguran que malí no tiene
que acatar sus advertencias y
recomendaciones
cientos de malienses demostraron en las
calles su apoyo al gobierno de
transición y a su líder así migoya en
los últimos dos años malí ha enfrentado
dos golpes de estado
varias potencias y organismos como la
onu y ecowas piden a la junta militar
que gobierna que organice elecciones en
febrero pero los manifestantes dijeron a
estas organizaciones que se ocupen de
sus propios asuntos
[Música]
salimos a manifestar para mostrar a la
opinión nacional e internacional que es
el pueblo de malí quien decide su
destino por eso estamos aquí
los manifestantes también expresaron
consignas contra francia a pesar de años
de operaciones militares dirigidas por
este país contra grupos yihadistas no se
ha logrado detener la violencia en el
país
[Música]
viene principalmente para apoyar así me
gusta quien también está pidiendo la
salida de francia los manifestantes
llevaban banderas de rusia como una
forma de decir que malí puede hacer
tratos con el grupo paramilitar ruso
warner y varios organismos
internacionales han advertido contra
este movimiento diciendo que tal alianza
podría traer más dificultades para los
malienses
26 artefactos de un valor incalculable
que fueron saqueados de benin por las
tropas francesas en el siglo 19
comenzaron el proceso de retorno a casa
una medida calificada como histórica
pero el ministro de cultura de benin
dice que los artículos equivalen sólo a
una restitución parcial y pide que se
devuelvan todas las piezas robadas
una última mirada antes de que estos
tesoros invaluables regresen al lugar
que corresponden en la exhibición 26
artefactos saqueados hace casi 130 años
por el ejército francés del antiguo
reino de dahomey en el sur de benin
desde entonces han sido expuestos en
varios museos franceses más
recientemente en el que only en parís
estas piezas de arte son de esencial
importancia para venir hace más de un
siglo que estas piezas fueron retiradas
de su contexto histórico
la decisión de francia tiene
ramificaciones potenciales de gran
alcance para los museos europeos los
artefactos saqueados durante la era
colonial pueden ser encontrados en
famosas colecciones públicas un ejemplo
los bronces de benin robados de la
actual nigeria por el ejército británico
en 1987 que se han alojado en toda
europa desde ese entonces
alemania ha dicho que devolverá más de
mil bronces y el museo británico de
londres también discute los planes de
devolver los artefactos sin embargo
también ha advertido que eso podría
tener como consecuencia el diezmo de las
colecciones de occidente durante décadas
este museo ha estado involucrado en un
tira y afloja con grecia por los
mármoles del partenón siempre se ha
rehusado a devolver las estatuas tomadas
de atenas en el siglo 19
el museo británico se encuentra en una
posición muy difícil porque está
regulado por un acta de ley un acta de
parlamento pasa igual en francia pero se
podría decir que su gobierno tiene una
visión más clara sobre estos asuntos que
el gobierno británico
los expertos dicen que hasta un 90% de
artefactos culturales africanos fueron
sacados del continente pero establecer
cómo llegaron a manos europeas es una
tarea complicada
muchos fueron legítimamente presentados
como obsequios adquiridos por
coleccionistas de arte africanos o
descubiertos durante expediciones
científicas
vamos ahora a nigeria que se ha
convertido en la primera nación africana
en lanzar una moneda digital -la y nayra
esto sigue a una prohibición nacional
sobre el comercio de cripto monedas
introducida en febrero que no ha logrado
detener el creciente interés en el
sector más en el siguiente informe bueno
un anuncio hecho directamente por el
presidente de nigeria un jamón dibujar y
elogió el lanzamiento del y nayra
diciendo que la moneda digital podría
ayudar a expandir el acceso a la banca y
hacer crecer la economía en miles de
millones de dólares
[Aplausos]
el uso de las monedas digitales del
banco central pueden ayudar a que las
personas y las empresas se alejen del
sector informal hacia el sector formal y
de futbolsexta la y nayra mantendrá la
paridad con la moneda nacional de
nigeria la nayra y su valor estará
garantizado por el banco central del
país esta es la diferencia de otras
cripto monedas como bitcoin que solo
está regulada en el salvador nigeria vio
recientemente un auge en el comercio de
cifrado ya que una población es joven y
conocedora de la tecnología comenzó a
buscar alternativas al debilitamiento de
lana era una tendencia que continuó a
pesar de que el banco central introdujo
una prohibición de las cripto monedas en
febrero al lanzar su propia licitación
digital el banco ahora espera obtener
mayor control sobre lo que se ha
convertido en un sector importante de la
economía pero muchos entusiastas de
cripto dicen que esta moneda primero
tendrá que ganarse su confianza
antes de considerar invertir en ella
he tenido problemas para confiar en el
banco central con las cripto monedas
porque ya las han prohibido pero ahora
lanzan su propia moneda digital así que
básicamente me gustaría en primer lugar
mirar y observar estuvo watch and
observé muchos inversores también se
preguntaron si podrían volver a cambiar
fácilmente su y nayra a la moneda normal
algo que el banco central aún tiene que
aclarar
y finalizamos esta emisión de áfrica
siete días en sudáfrica con las imágenes
de la semana de la moda sudafricana el
evento contó con la presencia del
público por primera vez desde el inicio
de la pandemia y se llevó a cabo en el
municipio de sánchez cerca de
johannesburgo los diseñadores buscan
hacer de ésta una feria única en el mapa
de la moda y en la que diferentes
orígenes y aspectos multiculturales
forman creaciones únicas
[Música]
y hasta aquí este capítulo de áfrica
siete días recuerde que si quiere
repetir esta u otra emisión de nuestro
programa lo puede hacer a través de
nuestra página web www punto frente 4
punto com
[Música]